[Applause]
all right he is an entrepreneur and
musician subtitled solo Michael was
recently released up for three Grammys
Sunday Killer Mike is with us Mike
render and he's the Republican governor
of New Hampshire Governor Chris sonunu
and she's the host of The Five on Fox
News Jessica TLO that's our panel that
we just had so would you like to uh
comment on my editorial that I just did
about how there's a lot of materialism
in music these days and maybe it's not
great for the kids I I think there's
materialism in American society period
you're we're just musicians and ARS a
lot of times in terms of when art
becomes Commerce it's just a reflection
of where a society is when you were
talking about you know it used to be a
lot of and hoes and homophobia
in there um hoes and homosexuals
by music and at a certain point the
people who make music was like it's not
cool to keep saying this because
they got better biding power than just
the guys who are mad at home and what
you see now is the people on top of the
chks of the Kendrick Lamar The Drakes
the J hes because Society um what it um
huy said it's not the Vanguard that
moves the people it's not the leadership
is when the people are ready to move so
I think
that I think when I when I have
arguments with the NAA my 26y old
daughter I know that there's a change
coming because of the way she views the
world so I think musicians and artists
for Commerce are going to adjust but
when it comes to money we have an
infatuation with money in this country
you know so much to the point we went
and kidnapped a bunch of people for
years ago made him work for free and
said boom greatest nation in the world
so you know happy black history M happy
black history M it's it's like a
relationship fight you never let it go
no you
can't I'll tell you this speak speaking
of money you want to let it go give
prepare reparations package for this for
this for black people in this country
for people and and and I and I and I'll
tell you this the leader of the FED say
did I buy dinner last time yeah you did
you
did and the restaurant that does not
count you did you offered to marry my
wife if I died early absolutely but I I
do think this country could benefit from
a reparations package that included a
cash that included reversal of red
lining by helping black people be
homeowners understand credit and
understand Americans that if if the
black community has more money this
country has more money and and we need
to start seeing ourselves in a
relationship as long as we have the
topic on the table what do you think
about that
B ramaswami just texted me his Taylor
Swift playlist I haven't been paying
attention so I'll way you're dodging
this question I'll Dodge out in terms of
what reparations reparations sending out
a check uh someone's got to pay no no
I'm not I'm not for reparations I'm not
I'm not for that at all um at the end of
the day uh this country owes 34 trillion
and the government doesn't owe that
money you all owe that money don't be
fooled the money got come difference
between Collective guilt and individual
why I don't want you feel guilty no I I
don't because I didn't do it I think
more black conserv but you benefited
from it you benefited from it and you
still benefit from it yes that's true
too my thing is my thing is just help
spread the benefits but okay but you
know there are reparations that do go on
in different ways yeah absolutely and I
didn't say absolutely just give me a few
million dollars and I'm fine no I think
that trade and higher level education I
do think a cash payout I think that
there should be a mortgage forgiveness I
think that we should have an incentive
to incentivize black wealth in this
country Robert Smith black billionaire
had an interesting conversation where he
wanted to tax corporations 2% of wealth
imagine what 2% of multi-billion dollar
companies does for black um for black
society what it does is it creates a
place where it's not perfect but Atlanta
black people have opportunity and if you
talk to Governor Brian km in Georgia
Georgia we also have a republican
governor who I have a relationship with
for the last 10 years we've been number
one in business we've created over
60,000 jobs and have more jobs coming I
would challenge you to to help put
together a reparations package that made
the rest of America look more like the
opportunity he's from New Hampshire
that's not going to
happen but but is but is it if I
may Lord knows I didn't want to get into
a reparations discussion it would cost
you hundreds of dollars up there and
then you got the but again is it what
about the Native Americans who are you
know you you got to go down the when
we're rep don't you don't hear black
people arguing against reparations for
anyone we've never argued against res
reservations we've never argued against
any payouts for people America's wrong
we're simply saying while we're at the
table let's do something to Aid the
people that until 60 years ago lived in
a party 60 years is not very
long with with with Native Americans we
gave them the the casino industry what
about you know super could black people
have the marijuana industry well I'm
something like that we look at his
face would you would you give us
give us like that's give us marijuana
multi-billion dollar industry is still
fresh it's still growing why doesn't
Killer Mike have a marijuana life I'm
I'm out of the business will you call
Brian Kim for me I'll call Brian right
now I don't know any discussion's going
to go Brian's a great friend
but if you're going to buy marijuana I
was you do at the woods which is the
great pot shop here in La which I'm a
part owner of with Woody harlson uh okay
what do you think of the news that NASA
says the Moon is shrinking
Biden right am I right thank you finally
finally someone talk to some sense
perfectly fine under
Trump and now I was excited that I
didn't have to do the reparations
question and then got the moon
question which could be more complicated
doesn't that go in your headlines that
shouldn't exist uh bucket it really
should I mean but apparently I read this
too in USA Today uh apparently the moon
because the core is cooling or something
it's our fault
I I'm sorry why does it matter it it
doesn't okay I know but it it's funny
because you really could do a whole
sketch about that because we are so
blame happppy in this country somebody
has to take I think the moon's on OIC
and that's the whole
thing uh what do you think about
oh conservatives in Texas are talking
about Texas well this happens like every
two years this is Texas seceding they
love to talk about it they it started
out as its own country right for wild
Texas was its own we just we just had a
bill in New Hampshire we get it almost
every two years someone wants to Haley
your girl said she doesn't think that's
illegal come on she doesn't know why the
Civil War happened and she doesn't get
that secession is illegal yeah look I'm
not I'm not advocating for anyone to see
I don't think Nikki's advocating for any
of that no but she said she didn't think
it was illegal and it is illegal you
can't secede from the union that's like
number one we the we the United States
what I I think everybody understands
that's that's where we need to be we
need Nikki H needs a bit of a history
lesson I
mean
that's broader than the secession issue
what that's broader than the secession
issue if we go back to the whole slavery
I know I'm saying she she seems to have
skipped grades I don't know some some of
them I I look yeah yeah you want it you
want to you want to end this Trump
conversation once and for all you all
get behind Nikki Haley because that's
how you do it you beat Trump in The
Ballot Box I mean that that's it look
politics is not a spectator sport people
you got to get involved you got to vote
you got to participate you this
think but according to the polls but
according to the polls they won't they
won't nikk haly beats Biden by 1015
points according to
the everybody stop
yelling but the Moon is shrinking Bill
the Moon is shrinking I'm shrinking now
okay uh Jessica how much how damaging
could a potential No Labels presidential
ticket be for Joe Biden so this is an
official third party now no labels who
is this a bunch of Jo Joe Mansion it
says do what do you make of rumors Joe
Mansion will be their candidate oh
exciting well I'll start by saying the
No Labels folks are grifters and
everyone should know that they're just
trying to grifters grifters right yes
you don't think they're
sincere I think they're sincere like 40
minutes a day and then I think the rest
of it is just an attempt to
get people who feel disenfranchised like
they're looking around they're like
they're to 80-year-old guys I don't like
either of them give me more money give
me more money and they don't really care
what the outcome is and they justify it
by saying you know well it's going to
suck either way but apparently the top
polling No Labels ticket is Nikki Haley
as president and Joe Mansion as VP I
happen to think and Joe Mansion is not
my favorite Democrat though he voted
with us all the time and I'm thankful
for having someone in West Virginia um I
don't think he would do something like
that because it would just destroy an
entire Legacy that he's had um but they
do take more support from Trump than
they do from Biden this the same with
like RFK Jr um if he were able to get on
more than half a ballot or something
like that okay Elon Musk announced his
company neuralink oh this is a pretty
big story successfully implanted the
first microchip in a human's brain is
this a good thing I I yes I think it is
because I mean this is if you haven't
read the story the ability to actually
do things just by thinking about it for
people who don't have the use of their
limbs uh and this is you know like
like I I can't stop liking Elon he's
he's he's he's a he's a he's a weird guy
he is yeah and he does sometimes make it
hard to defend him Absolut I get that
but this is the promise of a guy like
this I mean who else is doing this I
can't even imagine how this is done like
I like I couldn't tell you how
electricity happens but I probably could
find
out it's a short Wikipedia But like how
do you get it so like just by thinking
about it you change the channel don't
but
uh that's pretty amazing and I think
it's going to you know there is lots of
people who going to benefit from this
totally I'm sure it'll be used for evil
at some point but for now it's wonderful
to give people anybody all things yeah
yes you eventually use it for evil
that's what goes back to your money you
got to Y sex is usually the first thing
they they they'll find a way for a guy
to jerk
off but just
by
uh a recent a a recent study found a
growing political divide between men and
women with younger women skewing much
more liberal than men this is not new
but I think it's just more prevalent I
think this the number I saw was 30
points that's that is a huge and that's
the abortion issue right as Republicans
we're losing young people we're losing
Suburban moms we're losing women
strictly on the abortion issue and that
that's that's just terrible for the
party I think it's abortion it's guns
it's climate change it's social justice
and Trump and and the Grabber
who's like The Who and now owing 83
million not with Trump I don't know why
you guys keep looking at Me 2 I know but
interesting what you two have in common
is that you both can't say yeah and of
course so I'm voting for Biden you both
can't do
that I just find that interesting he
can't say she can't say you can't say
Biden can't say and most white people
won't say I'll sit down and talk about
black people about real black issues
from a place where I know I'm going to
leave issue I'm talking about reer
racist like we don't want to
talk about that but when you say me and
him are the same you know we're the same
besides that we want end like been good
for my community that's that's and I'm
not
saying but you got to meet me at my
table not just going have lunch with a
black kid and think everything's okay at
least you're engaging with the question
now yeah right I get that I totally get
that have neighbor have neighborhoods
really changed I mean I I forget who I
the last three years worse I mean it's
it's tougher well neighborhoods and and
what's going on with crime with Public
Safety with all this it's just getting
worse and worse and worse and both
parties are to blame let's not make make
any well that's the thing I mean if you
live in a neighborhood and you see
administrations change and nothing else
changes that I I totally get that why
you would go what's the difference which
white guy is President doesn't make any
difference and a lot of people weren't
crazy about Obama didn't think he was
the radical change they always they they
projected that on him he would never
said I think Americans are comfortably
they're comfortably uncomfortable I
think that this country could be
radically better if we say we're going
to do something radical and hold
politicians feet to the fire on politics
and we're not we're just simply not
doing it and and and at some point we're
going to have to get off TV arguing for
entertainment and we're going to have to
retreat to our living rooms our after
church synagogues or MOS functions and
we're going to have to have real
discussions where we disagree and agree
and we find out what are the 10 things
that are best on a hyper local level
what could be realer than this
discussion if I could let me don't be
telling people to get off I want people
to watch TV but I want people to get
with people who they don't look like not
TV this TV well this TV I I like your
show I don't watch most of you guys
show shut up New Hampshire rappers
aren't rapping about it yet but but I
but I do want to say that the
discussions that are had here take to
your living rooms with your family
members you hadn't talked to because
they voted for the other guy and have
the discussion and find things you agree
with and on a hyper local level what's
more important to Americans should be
who's my city council person who's my
mayor and who's my governor and and and
and school board if you do that I
guarantee you you'll start to create
local change that then from the top down
they'll say we need to emulate that and
I'll give you a perfect example is a a
democratic judge named Asha Jackson
chief judge Asha Jackson in Georgia
creates the Pinnacle program that gives
people an opportunity not to fall pray
to recidivism and go back to jail you
get one year to clean your up then
you graduate you go on you don't have to
go to prison Miss Ali is a woman out of
fton County juvenal court that was
appointed by our Republican Governor to
emulate that same thing Statewide so two
Democratic black women do something on a
local level that on the state level a
white Republican Governor recognizes and
then empowers to do the same thing
Statewide that's what we need to be
seeing hyper local instead of arguing
about the soap opera of the president it
see when you have those three Grammys in
your hands all right thank you everybody
we got to
[Applause]
go
that